I'm Brett Baer I'm Maria Bartiromo I'm
Brian Kilmeade and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday October 26 2022 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal a record number of Migrant
apprehensions in September only adds on
to what was already a record-breaking
fiscal year for migrant encounters at
the U.S Mexico border and it's on the
minds of many voters ahead of midterms
it's very clearly a national security
threat whether it's foreign terrorists
or simply the cartels themselves I'm
Dave Anthony
a lot of us might get sick this fall and
winter and it's not just covered the flu
is back and there's an RSV outbreak with
the masking with the hand washing with
the sanitizing with the distancing we
didn't see the viruses we usually see
and now we're seeing them and we're not
ready and we're not our immune systems
are not depressed and I'm Stephen Moore
I've got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
the latest Fox News Power Rankings ahead
of midterms have a few critical
adjustments just two weeks away from
election day in New York the governor's
race between Democrat Kathy hokel and
Republican Lee zeldin now moves from
likely Democrat to lean Democrat the
17th house district in New York where
Democratic Congressional Campaign
committee chairman Sean Maloney is
running is being moved from lean
Democrat to Tulsa the Republican
Tailwinds in some races come as one of
the more recent Fox News polls conducted
with parents shows after inflation crime
is the chief concern but the border is
on the list as well 67 percent said they
are very concerned about border security
this has Customs and Border Protection
says in September they apprehended a
record-breaking 227 thousand migrants to
make for a fiscal year with another
record nearly 2.4 million migrant
apprehensions not including 600 000
known gotaways in the year there were
also 98 border patrol arrests of
suspects on the FBI's Terror watch list
in fiscal year 2022 too that's nearly
quadruple the previous five fiscal years
combined Fox's film illusion in Eagle
Pass Texas White House spokeswoman green
Jean-Pierre says most of those coming
now are from places undergoing political
and economic turmoil the number of
individuals arriving from Venezuela
Nicaragua and Cuba was up 245 percent
from September of last year meanwhile
the number of migrants from Mexico and
Northern Central America America is down
nearly a quarter compared to just last
year some of the more moderate Democrats
like former Republican Florida Governor
Charlie Crist now running for governor
again as a Democrat are countering the
White House insistence that the border
is secure I mean it's not secure it
needs to be he said that on Fox's
America's Newsroom after debating
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis but
what can or will be done about some of
these issues many voters care about if
Republicans take the house but the
president is a Democrat there's a few
things one is actually extracting the
information we want from the
administration Dan challenge the
Republican Congressman representing
Texas district 2 which includes part of
Houston conducting the oversight
accountability the Democrats have no
interest in and they don't want to hold
the administration accountable they they
don't care about a border crisis they
they will seem to prefer it given the
policies they Implement so that'll be a
significant change and that and that
results in public pressure public
pressure can't help second you're going
to see our ideal legislation but like
you said it won't get passed even if we
retake a slim majority in the Senate we
won't have enough votes to really pass
serious policy unless we by Miracle get
Democrats actually cooperate and
Democrats editors and then Biden likely
wouldn't sign it but but you know we'll
still shoot for that and then you have
your must pass bills your budget
especially and that's where we might be
able to slip in some things where we can
make some progress on the border the
fund infrastructure for the Border fund
better pay for our border agencies
morale is low and it's the least we
could do I want to see a task force
funded that specifically targets and
conducts intelligence in some of cartels
I I don't think that is a subject that
gets talked about enough the the danger
of this potential failed State on our
Southern border that is completely
controlled by cartels that's actually
leads to my next question that I had
um because you served in the military we
know your former Navy SEAL so I want
that hat on as I ask this question you
know we have 600 000 known gotaways this
past year 98 names of people caught who
match names on the terror screening
database I've seen you have referenced
the fentanyl coming in as of other
Republicans we've seen people from all
over the world use the U.S Mexico border
as a point of entry ukrainians used it
when they were fleeing Russia a U.N
report this summer called the U.S Mexico
border the most dangerous Border in the
world how do you characterize all of
this yeah well it's very clearly a
national security threat whether it's
foreign terrorists or simply the cartels
themselves I mean the cartels themselves
are funneling fentanyl into our country
and Lacing Street drugs is basically
poison and you know we're not acting
like it's an act of War but it is an act
of war and it's coming from a couple
organizations in particular if the
Jalisco cartels and in a lower cartel
and nobody even knows the names of these
cartels why isn't that plastered all of
our news channels you know as as the
national security threat that they are
that's a necessary next step in just the
narrative that we build the public
conversation that we have let's turn to
energy I see some members of the House
sent a letter to President Biden about
the quote-unquote unleashing U.S energy
right we've heard that a lot on the
campaign Trails it's a rough read this
letter it accused the president of
allowing for the possibility of no new
offshore leasing capacity and
essentially accused him of a plan that's
very destabilizing and they point in the
letter to what Europe is going through
and they said we're not far behind that
as well as California but as curious
that is is that an overreach because a
huge part of Europe's energy crisis is
natural gas from Russia and we produce
natural gas in abundance here
um yeah I'm not sure what you mean is it
an overstatement to say that we're not
far behind from what Europe is
experiencing with energy oh uh no it's
not I mean we're still a ways off
luckily there's a few reasons for that
we're luckier than Europe uh
geographically speaking and from a
resource standpoint but the Democrats
very clearly are putting policies in
place that would have actually put us in
that same situation so the path is very
clear and the difference could not be
clear between uh the path that
Republicans want the fact that Democrats
want on this particular issue it was odd
to see uh I think Biden said last week
that he's never done more for for energy
security and more than any other
president some ridiculous overstatement
like that so we fact checked them and
reminded everyone of all of the things
they've done against this industry you
know whether it's the Keystone Pipeline
that everybody knows about but that's
just one of 100 things what's much worse
is the changes in ferc rules which
governs pipeline permitting uh the
changes at EPA that have just made it
extensively more difficult for anyone to
build anything or take or for releases
or build pipelines I mean you you can't
increase production if you have no place
to put the oil or gas that you're taking
out and so the pipeline permitting is
extremely important here and they've
taken every step possible to stop it so
yeah I mean these letters are
unfortunately falling on deaf ears but
we're going to keep sending them because
if people have to know how bad this
Administration has been and and what
kind of policies you need to make it
better I mean a lot of the solutions are
simply reversing the Damage Done by the
body Administration reversing some of
these rule changes they've weaponized
every single agency in government
against this industry and so you
shouldn't be surprised that you're not
seeing an uptick in production even
though prices are at a very profitable
height really the solutions are fairly
simple we're way behind and then there's
the investment issue because yeah a lot
of it is the rhetoric a lot of it is the
mood and investors say you know know
what I want you to return money to
shareholders as opposed to investing in
new production because this government
just doesn't seem friendly to our
long-term plan so let's just return
money to shareholders instead of
investing in new production that that's
generally what you're seeing and that's
that's a result of the political
conversations that demonize oil and gas
let's talk about midterms briefly I know
House minority leader Kevin McCarthy has
said as he prepares for the possibility
of the GOP taking the house that we
cannot continue to spend the way we're
spending and he said this is where
Republicans may get involved in the debt
limit stop raising the debt limit under
that we hear talk about entitlement
programs like Social Security and
Medicare those may come under
consideration so would possibly Ukraine
funding
where are you on some of those things
that are getting talked about Ukraine
funding or Medicare and Social Security
funding
pretty wildly different subjects I've
seen the headlines the Republicans are
no longer supporting I mean that's
obviously not true but we are more
rational about it Kevin says we're not
going to have a blank check anymore just
saying look we need more oversight we
need to know exactly why you need this
much money and what we're getting for it
look I mean so far I like the result
Ukraine is winning it seems like this
investment has been quite good so anyone
who says this has not been a good
investment so far I'm not sure what
their priorities could possibly be now
that doesn't mean that there's not
honest questions to be asked like can we
also fund a task force that targets the
cartels south of our border that's a
direct national security threat okay so
in the end we're talking about money
that's like a couple percentage points
of our annual defense budget you know so
this isn't a ton of money this is not
what's breaking the budget when we talk
about our long-term debt and what could
potentially one day throw our country
into a financial crisis the things that
actually drive that you mentioned them
they're entitlements two-thirds of our
expenditures are entitlements think we
don't even vote on now we make a big
show income Congress arguing about the
debt limit and arguing about a few
billion dollars here there for Ukraine
or arguing about uh our discretionary
spending which is which is your annual
budget but the truth is two-thirds of
those expenditures are mandatory
spending Social Security and Medicare
and so until Americans want to have a
very serious conversation about about
what kind of entitlements they get as
they reach senior citizen age then this
will continue to be a problem if we're
going to have the conversation what
should we be talking about should we be
talking about raising the age limit like
should I be saving my money and and
maybe I get Medicare but not Social
Security like if if we have the
conversation what are some of the things
we should maybe be talking about or
considering in terms of specifics
yeah great question and and you know our
generation should be very frustrated by
this because what Democrats want to do
is raise our taxes and directly transfer
that to our grandparents now is that
fair because our grandparents had their
whole lives to save build their business
start their families and so should you
really be raising taxes on People of Our
Generation who have not had that chance
yet and no and the answer is no I don't
think we should and so but but what
should we give I mean what should be our
contribution to this and you said it
it's raising the retirement age we're
living a lot longer than our
grandparents Generation Dead and and
you've got to accept the fact too that
our demographics have changed wildly
where our population has aged a lot and
continues to age because people are
living longer we have less workers in
the workforce paying into this program
and so like there's a popular belief out
there that all the government rated it
it's all just you know it was used for
other things that's not true as you know
it's a myth and the truth is is it's
insolvent it's going insolvent because
of demographic changes so this is a long
and complicated conversation I know but
you've got to Tinker with the with the
equations on both sides right into it
and what kind of benefits are coming out
of it well and it sounds like if the GOP
does win the house we'll be having more
of this conversation finally Before I
Let You Go
ahead of these midterms right we hear
what Republicans are saying but we also
hear what Democrats are saying I see
them on Twitter I'm sure you do too they
say Republicans are scaring people ahead
of these midterms that inflation
wouldn't be so bad if the Trump tax cuts
were reversed congresswoman Katie Porter
from California for example pointed to
corporate profits as the inflation
driver what is your response to this
these people have never taken an
economics class I I just blows my mind
it's especially concerning because well
Trump tax cuts did was yeah of course it
was a boon for businesses and when
things are rebooted for businesses what
happens you see an uptick in production
and Supply you see you're not taking
employment that's exactly what happened
so it was all good everything was good
now the pandemic hit now this was an
external Factor but we also screwed up
our response to it wildly lockdowns
permanently disfigured a lot of supply
chain and obviously not just our
lockdowns but worldwide lockdowns
lockdowns we couldn't control but at the
end it was bad policy supported by
democrats that led to this and unless
it's sort of a supply crisis into the
supply-driven inflation followed by an
excessive amount of money put into the
hands of the public through lots of
different spending programs and so you
you do all this and you have way more
dollars chasing fewer guts because of
the supply chain crisis that took place
that's what caused inflation this isn't
rocket science it's a very basic
economics and for Democrats to even use
this pseudoeconomic science talking
points to try and describe inflation is
just so just absurdly and horrifically
dishonest and improves they have no
business governing in this country and
that's all I would say about that
Congressman Dan Crenshaw thanks so much
for your time great being on with you
thank you
[Music]
this is Stephen Moore with your Fox News
commentary coming up
President Biden has rolled up his sleeve
again getting another covet vaccine jab
months after he got coveted the
president got a dose of the new updated
booster offering more protection from
omocron variants and he's urging all
those already vaccinated ages five and
older to get a shot too update your
vaccine your covered vaccine it's
incredibly effective but the truth is
not enough people are getting it just
under 20 million Americans have gotten
this booster so far the president is
also urging Congress to approve more
funding to fight covid Republicans say
we've already overspent claiming that
has led to inflation if you really want
to put cover behind us we have to keep
up the fight together now one of the
concerns is funding could dry up on
vaccines I think that the new bivalent
booster is actually working better than
we thought it would in producing
antibodies against this virus Dr Mark
Siegel is a Fox News contributor and
professor at NYU langone health I like
it as a tool in my Arsenal all of the
confusion Dave has come from this issue
of what does a vaccine do what is the
purpose of a vaccine there are two
purposes one is to keep you from getting
very sick like the flu shot which is
fairly good the other is to keep it from
spreading to others there's been a
dramatic realization in this country
that this vaccine the MRNA vaccine
doesn't do a great job keeping you from
spreading it to others does it do any
job at all at that it does do some
actually it decreases your risk of
spread to some extent but somebody like
the president who's pushing 80 we want
him to have as much immunity as possible
on board okay where did you get that
immunity from he gets some of it from
the covet case he just had at some point
we need an additional layer of immunity
as we get more variants circulating
around someone that just gets over
coveted they got a lot of protection and
they're probably not going to get sick
again so it would be complete Overkill
to give them a shot okay but you said
not sick again for how long how long
does this natural immunity last how much
longer will he have immunity by getting
a booster there's talk about we may get
a shot every year for some sort of a
variant you know even as I'm saying I
like this poster there's a new
sub-variant creeping along that's
actually not great against this booster
so the damn virus is evolving at light
speed and it's pushing out more
subvariants and these are very specific
vaccines and they've gotten a lot of bad
press which I don't think they deserve
by the way but we're going to have
better vaccines do I think we're going
to need a covet shot once a year the way
we get a flu shot once a year or again
an inhaled version probably but it won't
be this one all right that brings us to
the next question about these covert
vaccines and whether or not they will be
and there's a debate now controversial
with CDC recommendations whether or not
this will go on to the schedule of
vaccines children
babies
will be getting part of the same group
of vaccines that that we always give
kids
yeah the the controversy over what you
should give children is really been very
political and not MediCal I'm very
disturbed about it you know what's
dangerous to kids Dave
this virus is and even though kids don't
get very sick from it and they don't get
very sick from it in general some do
there's been over a thousand deaths from
covid among children there was Miss C
which was a multi-system disease that's
gotten cut down a lot and there's
hospitalizations among kids and the most
important concern I have about kids is
long covet brain fog fatigue that
persists now I absolutely believe that
the Omicron subvariants are milder
they're milder for kids and they're
milder for everyone but I'm still in a
situation where I feel that even milder
than the virus is the vaccine so I like
the idea of most kids having some layer
of vaccine immunity again depending on
who they are depending on what their
risk factors are depending on how they
responded to previous vaccines and I
think the white house is way off
suggesting boosters for everyone over
the age of five that's way Overkill okay
that's way over overstated but
let me back up what age then would you
make it I don't think that the whole
problem with this pandemic has been
mandates and you know one size fits all
I'm making a good case for kids getting
the vaccine especially since we have an
obesity epidemic in the United States
one half to two-thirds of all kids are
overweight that is a risk factor for
having us getting sicker from covid so I
would be considering giving this to
everybody over the age of five but I
wouldn't make a statement like that I
get in the doctor's office where again
we still don't have the vaccine I'd like
the vaccine in the pediatrician's office
and then let them have a discussion with
the parents and the kids once you have
the primary series it may be enough you
may not need to be boosted if you're
very young there are those who think
that this vaccine has too many side
effects or they can worried about what
the vaccine itself could do to children
there was talk about there were heart
problems but 10 initially for younger
males who get a covert vaccine shot your
thoughts on that this has been way over
exaggerated the the here are the numbers
the latest study out of Israel published
in the New England Journal of Medicine
shows one out of 15
000 male teens that got this shot got a
mild case of myocarditis which went away
in all cases nobody died
the thing that nobody's saying is that
there's a risk of myocarditis from covid
and that your risk is likely greater if
you haven't been vaccinated so those
cases where you get a heart problem from
covid we're seeing more hospitalizations
we've seen some deaths I'm much more
concerned about the risk of heart
problems from covid in male teens than I
am about myocarditis I'm not ignoring
this point I think it's part of that
discussion you have in the office but
another thing that you didn't mention is
the risk of changes in menstrual cycles
I think that's real I don't think that
should be downplayed I think that's
likely temporary but that's part of
making the decision you know you have to
put that on the table when covid first
hit back in 2020 people were tired had
trouble breathing some lost taste and
smell that has all been changing over
time evolving researchers from Mass
General Hospital Harvard Stanford and
King's College in London did a joint
study on symptom items and found coveted
patients most commonly report headaches
sore throats runny noses and a
persistent cough these days no matter if
they were vaccinated or not this is
affecting upper respiratory Airways not
the lungs that's really important
because the original variants went right
for the lungs and a lot of people ended
up on ventilators or within compromised
lung function these Omicron variants and
subvariants are mostly upper respiratory
so you have a cough but it's not as deep
a cough so you have respiratory
congestion you have a sore throat you
have a runny nose you still have a fever
milder that brings us to flu cold RSV
those things have similar symptoms so as
we get into the fall and winter is it
going to be a little confusing for
people what do I have do I have covid do
I have the flu what do I have you know
I'm I'm facing that right now I I have a
very active clinical practice and I'm
getting calls all the time and I'm going
to tell you how I differentiate we have
a rapid covert test we have a rapid flu
test we don't have a rapid RSV test so I
use that as a diagnosis of exclusion and
if a person's particularly sick I have
them come into our testing center and I
can test them for RSV by the way so I
can do a respiratory panel here's the
way I tell the difference high fever I
generally don't associate with covid
right now for the reason you just said
high fever I'm thinking of flu or
another respiratory virus but the rest
of it's the same upper respiratory
congestion fatigue muscle aches that can
be any of them so I am telling you we're
expecting a worse flu season this year
because we don't have immunity to flu
built up I'm telling you that we have a
big RSV outbreak going on right now and
I'm telling you that we still have coven
and we're getting a Resurgence of
certain variants the answer is obvious
get your flu shot get your coven booster
if you're in an address this group
especially and stay home if you're sick
I mean that's something we've seemed to
have forgotten because with coveted we
were telling people to stay home who
weren't sick just because they'd been
exposed that was a mistake that was
carried on too long we didn't have
enough testing and we kept people home
who were exposed that depleted the
workforce go to work if you feel well
stay home if you're sick now one thing
that we did and right when covet hit in
2020 not only did we stay home and have
distancing and wear masks we also you
know was a lot more hand washing because
people feared that we could spread covet
you know on groceries that were
delivered or something like that and
then we used a lot of Purell until we
couldn't find Purell we did do a lot
more hand washing and avoiding shaking
hands and avoiding the way that usually
colds and flu gets spread we we don't
we've been doing we need to stop doing
some of that and we didn't I haven't got
a cold in years so now I'm back in the
office and I expect to get another one
you know what I'm saying it's a
brilliant observation I think it's 100
True I'd add to that something called
the hygiene hypothesis which is that
we're now being we're used to being
exposed to germs and that keeps our
immune system on the alert with the
masking with the hand washing with the
sanitizing with the distancing we didn't
see the viruses we usually see and now
we're seeing them and we're not ready
and we're not our immune systems are not
prepped what about the common cold
well the common cold is often a form of
coronavirus by the way rhinoviruses
coronaviruses Echo viruses we're going
to be seeing a lot of that and I go back
to my old uh recommendations hydration
you know you can take a Mucinex if
you're coughing if you feel miserable
you want to keep temperatures down you
want to stay home if you're sick RSV you
mentioned RSV there's a big outbreak
what is the concern with RSV why what
makes RSV different and maybe more
concerning than flu or covid you know
this this was hardly reported last
October but we had a problem with RSV
then and and the number of
hospitalizations from very young
children went up and everyone thought it
was coveted and to some extent it was
coveted but to a larger extent it was
RSV and the reason is because RSV clogs
the upper Airways with mucus and if
you're a tiny tot you don't have big
Airways and so if they get clogged you
may have problems with breathing and you
may end up in the hospital that's the
pathway for RSV for very young children
and it's something we have to be very
concerned about you know when this covet
era people were always afraid we lived
afraid afraid of getting coveted now we
have all these things in the fall in the
winter are we all going to get something
I think you're right I think we are and
I think we've become paranoid of every
sniffle and I think it's time we return
to to life and I think we we learned
that the greatest damage of shutting
down was not the virus Dr Mark Siegel
professor of medicine at NYU langone
Health Fox News contributor always good
to talk to you thank you so much Dave
great pleasure today thank you
and in other news I'm Gianna jalozzi
shrinking seats and reduced leg room
have become the norm for flights the
Federal Aviation Administration that was
considering some new safety standards
including seat dimensions and Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer says
they're doing it quietly the New York
Democrat urging the public to create
some turbulence warning the ghosts of
the shrinking airline seat is back the
issue centers on airplane safety the FAA
long maintained that if airplane seats
no matter the size don't extend the
evacuation time Beyond 90 seconds
there's no need to lay out and set
minimum requirements and it's not their
problem whether you're comfortable or
not in your seat but consumer groups
Health experts and some members of
Congress like Schumer disagree they say
it's a mistake to only take into account
the safety side of things instead of
comfort too legroom has dropped from
about 35 inches before Airline
deregulation in the 1970s to about 31
inches and see width has been cut from
18 and a half inches in the 19 90s in
the 2000s to about 17 inches that
according to Schumer's office this while
the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention data shows that the average
American man is about 30 pounds heavier
now than in the 60s the same goes for
women public comment opened on August
3rd the FAA has received nearly 15
000 comments many like Senator Schumer
hope the FAA will intervene and set a
standard for seat sizes you have until
November 1st to submit your comment for
the Fox News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my name is Kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will I humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's Kennedy Saves the World
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com Raiden review the
Fox News rundown on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
Fox News commentary Steven Moore what's
on your mind everywhere I go people are
mystified about President Joe Biden's
economic agenda I'm asked the same
question over and over again by people
is Biden intentionally trying to take a
wrecking ball to the economy is this all
part of some kind of diabolical plan the
great reset to end our system of free
market capitalism and replace it with
some form of big government socialism
my belief is that the answer to that is
no I don't think this is an intentional
plot by a nefarious Dr Evil type
character
but if this were a scheme to burn down
the village in order to rebuild it Biden
and his administration are doing a great
job of it aren't they
here are seven Biden Administration
steps to undermine an economy in a
society from within
number one
dismantle the nation's energy Supply
we get 70 percent of our energy from
fossil fuels Biden has declared war on
American Oil and Gas making us more
dependent on our enemies for our basic
energy needs
number two don't enforce the Border
immigration is good for our country but
it must be orderly and regulated number
three devalue the nation's currency
through inflation inflation is up nearly
nine percent since Biden came into
office
number four destroy the nation's
finances by running up the debt by
multiple trillions of dollars
no president in modern times has so
recklessly pushed our nation into debt
as rapidly as Joe Biden has through his
four trillion dollars in spending paid
for with Reddick
number five divide the nation rather
than unite us
Rich versus poor black versus white gay
versus straight rural versus Urban Biden
promised to unify the country instead he
continues to pit groups against each
other
number six dumb down and indoctrinate
our children with anti-American
propaganda in the schools and the media
and allow teachers unions and left-wing
activists to take over the curriculum
with anti-america propaganda
number seven let criminals out to the
streets and don't fight crime Biden's
policies favor criminals over victims
it's a scene out of a Batman movie
are these policies intentional are they
simply completely misguided I don't know
for sure but does it matter
either way our country is in grave peril
I'm Stephen Moore a senior fellow at the
Heritage Foundation and an economist
with freedom Works my latest book is
Godzilla how the Relentless growth of
government is devouring our economy
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
Jason in the house the Jason Chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as I take on American
Life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts